let me ask about Paul morphy
how good was he uh Reddit asked me to
ask you about this and and why is he a
tragic figure in chess yeah so Paul
morphe was the best player in the world
by a bigger margin probably than anyone
else in recent modern history he was I
would say roughly using today's ratings
around like 2 400 in my opinion and the
other best players were maybe around
2000 or 2100 at best so he's the best
player by a bigger margin Fisher for
example I think it was about 170-ish
points um better than Boris basket but
more if it was 300 plus at least now by
modern standards he would probably be a
very strong I am uh which you know is
isn't saying a whole lot but at the time
no one was even close so I don't think
you can put him in that category of like
best ever simply because he was not the
best player for a long enough period of
time
um as far as why it's tragic it's very
tragic because he essentially quit chess
there was no competition for him uh if
you think about like Magnus talking
about the world championship and feeling
like it's not competitive enough for
morphe there was no one who could even
beat him probably in individual games so
he ended up quitting chess I think he
was sort of like a lawyer kind of but he
spent probably the last 15 I think last
15 20 years of his life just doing
nothing now I have actually seen his
grave in New Orleans I have been to
where where he lived I think it's now
Brennan's if I'm not mistaken or
something like that
um so it's very tragic that there was no
one who was competitive with him at the
time
um as far as best ever I don't I don't
think you can say he's the goat but I
still think he's in the top 10 if we're
using a criteria of players who were
better than their peers by a big big
margin